salut cette semaine on est parti pour
une série de vidéos un petit peu étrange
puisqu'on va parler de rubik's cube à la
fin de cette vidéo vous serez en mesure
de réaliser un rubik's cube en moins de
deux minutes et avec cinq formules sacs
et demi on va dire grand maximum et dans
cette première vidéo on va comprendre
comment fonctionne un rubik's cube de
calais ce que cet étrange objet orbi-xxi
vous ça a été inventé en 1974 par
monsieur rubik
c'est pour ça que c'est le rubik's cube
c'est le cube de monsieur rubik et dans
les années 80 c'est devenu hyper à la
mode tout le monde en avait un il y en
avait des deux sur deux des trois sur
trois des quatre sur quatre on va
apprendre à résoudre le plus populaire
le 3 sur 3 oui parce qu'on y résoudre un
rubik's cube donc le rubik's cube est
composé de six face là il ya la blanche
la verte la jaune la bleue la rouge et
la orange lorsqu'on a le rubik's cube de
on reçoit cette partie là c'est la face
à ces le dessus le dessous la droite la
gauche et l'arrière mais attention parce
que si je me mets dans cette position ça
ça devient la face le dessus dessous la
gauche la droite et l'arrière au niveau
de sa structure parce que le rubik's
cube à une structure c'est pas magique
ça tient pas tout seul il ya à
l'intérieur un axe à trois branches et
chaque branche finit par une couleur ce
sont les éléments centraux du rubik's
cube c'est ce qui fait que ces éléments
là ne bougeront jamais en réalité on va
déplacer tout le tour on ne pourra
jamais déplacé les axes centraux puisque
eux sont fixes et après c'est un habile
jeu d' équilibre entre les coins et cela
qui fait que tout ça ça tient et qu'on
puisse tout bouge et c'est ce qui nous
donne d'ailleurs l'illusion que le
rubik's cube est complètement libre
c'est faux le rubik's cube et
emprisonnent une fois qu'on sait ça on
sait tous on sait presque tout on sera
tous à la fin de la septième vidéo dans
cette première vidéo vous allez
comprendre comment résoudre la première
phase on mélange on le casse dans tous
les sens vous le reconnaissez c'est lui
qui vous a fait pleurer qui vous a fait
vous énervez qui vous a fait le casser
voire même décollé des gommettes ne
mentez pas je sais que vous avez déjà un
jour décoller des gommettes pour les
remettre dans le bon sens dans la
méthode du rubik's cube
le plus simple est d'essayer de créer la
première phase donc celle qu'on a face à
soi tout en respectant la première
couronne parce que si là je crée une
phase avec uniquement les blancs et
qu'ici sur la première couronne des
couleurs ne sont pas respectés et unis
alors c'est sûr que je pourrais pas le
fini la première phase en respectant la
première couronne après on verra comment
faire la deuxième couronne et après non
pas comment faire la troisième d'un coup
on placera d'abord les plots centraux
ensuite on placera les coins les
mettrait dans le bon sens et bref tout
ça on verra
très facile je peux vous le garantir
vous allez y arriver parce qu'on est
ensemble on est une équipe on a un
contrat peut-être jeu trop loin donc je
pourrais vous apprendre des formules
pour créer la première phase mais
d'après moi la première phase elle peut
se faire en toute logique c'est le plus
simple et ça vous aidera à comprendre le
rubik's cube et à pouvoir anticiper
après on va se prendre comme point de
repère la case blanche avec le v6 comme
ça on va savoir où on en est et je vais
vous apprendre toutes les logiques
possible sur les mouvements du rubik's
cube donc regardons ce rubik's cube
ici j'ai un blanc vert magnifique blanc
vert et j'aimerais le placer ici et là
déjà vous avez envie de quitter cette
vidéo mais ne le faites pas vous allez
comprendre à quel point c'est simple je
vais commencer par l'isoler celui qui
est juste là je vais l'isoler en
tournant juste là sur ma droite celui du
bas donc le blanc vert est ici et je
veux descendre cette partie la centrale
pour faire comme ça n'est jamais vu
quelqu'un dont un remix cube et faire ça
la solution c'est de descendre ces deux
blocs là d'un coup et de remonter celui
ci je vous en faire voir de plus près
d'abord je maintiens tous tout le côté
gauche pour descendre les deux autres
puisent maintient le côté gauche et le
central pour remonter celui-là ça
revient exactement la même chose que
faire ça une fois que j'ai fait ça je
ramène celui que j'avais mis de côté ici
magie il s'est placé et pour remonter
cet art est comme ça et je vais faire le
chemin inverse de tout à l'heure je
bloque celui de gauche et le central je
descends suite droite je bloque que
celui de gauche je remonte les deux il
est en place j'en ai donc de placer sur
ma face maintenant je vais essayer de
placer un des deux points ici pour
continuer ma face blanche avec la
couronne verte
donc je vais chercher un coin kg et
blanc vert est autre chose
et ici ça tombe bien j'ai du vert blanc
rouge ça tombe bien comme si c'était
surprenant de le trouver ce pas très
grande
je veux laisser mon doigt dessus pour
que vous puissiez bien suivre ici j'ai
le vert rouge et blanc et je veux le
monter soit ici soit ici déjà je vais
tourner cette partie basse pour vous
puissiez voir où est ce qu'il est donc
le cube qui nous intéresse c'est la vert
rouge blanc et on va vouloir le monte
quelque part ailleurs
ma priorité c'est d'avoir cette phase
blanche ici ou ici parce que pour
l'instant elle est en dessous allez
allez pas visibles pour faire
je vais passer ce cube là ici en dessous
je vais tourner ici de 90° inverse est
là enfin ça devient visible pour que
vous compreniez bien ce que j'ai fait je
me remets dans la position d'avant il
était ici je les déplacer là j'ai tourné
comme ça et je vais passer derrière la
caméra pour que vous puissiez bien
comprendre le mouvement final on a
toujours notre blanc ici notre blanc
vers la ici blanc rouge vert maintenant
je veux que cette phase blanche à l'ail
ici
en clair que ce bloc la remplace celui
ci donc déjà je vais l'amener au bon
endroit juste là et ce cube là j'ai
besoin de le monter là donc pour ça je
vais le mettre sur le côté pour le
réserver le protégé ici là juste là je
descends je descends l'art est de gauche
je ramène l'arête du bas pour le
positionner à la place et je remonte
l'ensemble en clair celui ci est venu
chercher celui que j'avais mis de côté
et là ça commence à prendre forme et je
sais maintenant que cet art est là sera
la rouge puisque j'ai commencé aussi ma
colonne rouge et ça tombe bien parce que
ici le rouge blanc est exactement
positionner comme je voudrais mais par
contre pas du tout dans le bon sens donc
je vais commencer par descendre l'arête
centrale avec le même méthode que tout à
l'heure je le veux décalé d'un côté ici
ça m'a permis d'enlever ce cul plat de
sa place initiale
maintenant je peux le repositionner sous
la redd qui m'intéresse ici et là je
sais déjà que vous dites c'est très
compliqué en fait ça c'est un cas
d'école très simple il faut dans votre
esprit que vous oubliez cet art est la s
arrête là qu'on se concentre uniquement
sur celles du centre
et si on se concentre sur celle du
centre on voit que lui
il faudrait juste tourner complètement
le cube pour le placer devant et c'est
ce que je vais faire c'est ce que je
vais faire mais comme je veux pas casser
mon montage je descends celui du centre
uniquement et la regarder il se retrouve
derrière
l'endroit que je voudrais donc je vais
faire 180 degrés et forcément il se
positionne en bon endroit et je remonte
l'ensemble avec la même méthode qu'on a
vu depuis le départ et on en a passé 4
400 places et donc
un coin j'ai vraiment conscience que
c'est le plus compliqué de faire la
première phase pourrait vous apprendre à
faire une croix et avoir des formules
pour le résoudre
mais ça me pose deux problèmes le
premier c'est que ça vous fait encore
des formules à apprendre
alors que j'aimerais que vous en ayez
que cinq maximum à retenir est le
deuxième c'est que si vous n'utilisez
que des formules vous n'aurez pas la
logique du rubik's cube autant là ça
vous paraît peut-être un petit peu
abstrait au départ de faire la première
phase avec la première couronne autant
ensuite ça vous paraîtra très simple
vous n'y penserez même plus et vous
aurez en tête la logique du rubik's cube
vous allez pouvoir le décomposer un
petit peu mentalement ce sera plus
simple par exemple si je reste dans ma
logique je sais que la sévère lacets
rouges si je cherche un autre cube qui a
rouge blanc rouge blanc rouge blanc ou
ouais tu ici rouge blanc bleu
je vois que c'est le bleu qui est
associé aux derniers rouge blanc donc je
peut en déduire tout de suite que ça va
être le bleu ici puisque mont blanc
rouge sera bleu ici donc je peux
m'amuser à l'anticiper puisque je sais
déjà que ce sera bleu ici et encore par
les déductions je sais que ce sera le
ronge ici un cas particulier pour les
cubes centraux que je vais vous
apprendre un résultat très facilement
c'est quand un du centre là le blanc
orange qui va ici et sur le côté au lieu
d'être sur le banc si on visualise bien
on se dit bien que si on tournait celui
ci comme ça il se mettra dans la bonne
position donc c'est ce qu'on va faire on
le met dans la bonne position et ensuite
l'idée c'est de l'isoler du bloc combien
de bouger pour pouvoir remettre le bloc
en place mais garder celui ci isolé donc
je tourne sur le côté et je remonte le
blog tel qu'il était et la mont blanc
orange ne demande qu'à monte donc je
lise hall de ce côté je descends l'arête
centrale avec la méthode qu'on a vu tout
à l'heure
celui qui était sur le côté maintenant
je le place là où il va a gelé en
quelque sorte chargé sur l'arête à red
que je viens recherché pour vous monter
je repasse de l'autre côté de la caméra
pour mettez trois derniers angles alors
ici me manque le vert orange blanc qui
se trouve juste ici je vous positionnez
du bon côté il est là vers orange blanc
techniquement il doit prendre cette
place là donc je le lise hall sur le
côté je descends l'art est concerné je
le charge là où il va et je remonte
l'arête concerne ensuite il me manque le
orange bleu et blanc qui se trouve juste
là donc je le positionne pile poil sous
l'arrêt tout j'ai envie de le charger je
le vis seule je descends l'art est
concerné
je le charge et je remonte l'art est
concerné et le dernier donc bleu rouge
blanc qui se trouve là encore une fois
je le place sous l'art est concernée
parce que parce que ici ça n'aurait pas
d'intérêt
maintenant que je suis sûr de mon coup
je le lise hall je vais sans l'arête de
droite je la charge du bloc et je
remonte la règle de droit public
et qu'est ce qui vient de se passer eh
bien on a fait tout notre face et
surtout on a réalisé notre première
couronne en même temps je vous ai dit ce
sera sûrement la vidéo la plus complexe
à comprendre et appliquer faites le en
toute logique tâtonner dessus chercher
galère un petit peu regardé la vidéo
pour voir les cas d'école pour les
centraux pour les coins pour les mettre
dans le bon sens respecter bien la
première couronne
une fois que vous avez fait ça nous
avait fait tout ce chemin bref est le
plus long et surtout vous avez compris
la logique de ce magnifique rubik's cube
je vais vous laisser 24 heures pour
digérer ça tranquillement une fois que
vous avez bien compris que vous arrivez
à le faire de plus en plus facilement
essayé d'accélérer votre temps de plus
en plus sans aller plus loin toujours
juste la phase et la première couronne
et demain nous allons voir comment faire
la deuxième couronne à l'aide de deux
formules uniquement entraînez-vous bien
prenez bien soin de vous et rendez vous
demain à 17h pour ce prochain mentale
blog spécial rubik's cube ciao